as enterprises digitally transform
themselves networks are at the
foundation while networks are constantly
modified to support business
applications you need a single pane of
glass that can address all aspects of
troubleshooting and monitoring so that
complex connectivity and network
performance issues are easier to
diagnose Network Intelligence Center is
Google clouds framework for network
monitoring across the cloud and
on-premise it improves user experience
security and operations by providing a
comprehensive platform for monitoring
visualizing and troubleshooting network
health across the cloud and data center
network topology is a module in network
intelligence center that helps you
visualize your network so that you can
monitor your network health easily we
have heard from customers that
visualizing cloud topologies is not
trivial as the cloud network is really a
mesh everything talks to everything else
imagine 1,000 instances talking among
themselves there is also a difference
between an on-prem and cloud environment
and it's challenging to navigate and
understand the differences and customers
want to ensure that there is no gap
between tribal knowledge of their
deployment and reality so our goal is to
allow you to navigate the visualization
of your network with structure and
insights so that network monitoring and
troubleshooting becomes easier for you
you save time and in many cases avoid
network issues altogether let's start by
seeing a visualization of your project
which is your current deployment within
GCP on the top you can see all the
external clients we have traffic going
to three geographic regions here
Americas amia and APEC you can drill
down into any of these and see which
specific countries the traffic is coming
from or being served to in the middle
you have load balancers again you can
drill in and see all the different load
balancers deployed
on the bottom here you have your GCE
instances and the regions that they're
deployed in you can drill down to the
specific VM instance level as needed
many customers want to use this to
quickly verify certain policies for
instance let's say you have a policy in
which all the traffic should be going
through the load balancers you can click
on the GCE region or an external geo
region to see all the traffic and verify
the policy here you can see that there
is some traffic going directly from a
GCE instance to the Internet another
example of a common use case for
customers is to proactively verify if
the traffic is being served out of the
optimal region for instance here you can
see that the AIPAC clients are being
predominantly served out of the Asia
East region this would help you
troubleshoot performance issues that may
happen as a result of traffic being
served out of a non optimal region you
would be able to easily see which
regions the traffic is being served out
of you can also see the evolution of
topology by going back in time by
clicking on this timeline on the bottom
this is very useful in several scenarios
for instance if a network event happened
and you want to troubleshoot it you can
look at the topology around the event
using this capability to determine any
topology changes you may have
contributed to the network issue during
migration it helps you to monitor the
state of your deployment as you migrate
your workloads thus providing better
visibility into your migration process
and also letting you track it by looking
at the topology evolution through time
for troubleshooting the search
capability is very helpful for instance
if you wanted to search for a specific
instance and see what all it was talking
to or a specific load balancer you can
do all those kinds of search using this
capability that way you can drill down
into exactly what you're searching for
all edges and the visualization have
metrics associated with them you can
click on any edge and view how the
metric changed over a period of time you
can see through put in these metrics
ingress and egress bite counts and
others for monitoring your network
health if you have VPC flow logs
available and you want to drill in more
to analyze
those logs to make it simple we show you
the query to the actual flow logs that
contributed to this traffic you can
click on this link which will create the
query and show you the flow logs you can
also use some of these metrics for
optimizations for instance I am only
looking at the regions here and how you
could do certain optimizations by
understanding what's contributing to
egress traffic across regions here I'm
looking at traffic from US central one
to Europe west one and lastly you can
also look at your topology at the
organization level to get an overview of
all your projects you can see how your
projects are talking to each other and
verify that it meets your intent
congratulations you are all set up to
start using the network topology module
and network intelligence Center to
visualize monitor and troubleshoot your
network
you